so what'd you do last night yo I watched
the game and I wanted to watch the game
so bad but my girlfriend made me watch
The Bachelor yeah yeah you know I
actually only watched part of the game
cuz my girlfriend also made me watch The
Bachelor huh yeah my girlfriend thinks
Ben's pretty cool I mean my girlfriend
likes him but she doesn't buy the whole
I'm unlovable thing you know this my
girlfriend agrees see what my girlfriend
doesn't understand is why Ben keeps lace
around well my girlfriend thinks it's
cuz of the producers you know to keep
the show more interesting huh I guess my
girlfriend never thought about that
I don't know Julie what no way
now with Olivia still hanging around
that's my girlfriend's thought sorry
who's your girlfriend's favorite 20
Michelle 1 2 3
Emily what has your girlfriend react
when lb just walked off the show my
girlfriend thought she was insane Amy
wait that's a once in a lifetime
opportunity like my girlfriend would
kill to be on that show yeah hi
girlfriend also excuse us sir we're
gonna need you to hold see my
girlfriend's top four fantasy Pixar
Lauren H Lauren B Becca and Jojo but
what about Amanda she has two kids they
would make a beautiful family with Ben
at least that's what my girlfriend
thinks I guess you know what we're gonna
do the deal
I mean honestly my girlfriend thinks Ben
is better than Shawn it's your
girlfriend crazy better than Shawn Shawn
was the perfect fit for Kaitlyn are you
kidding me Ben and Kaitlyn together they
would have been in divorce court after
three months Shawn was the perfect
person for Kaitlyn he was a strong
strapping young man that's perfect and
just fits perfectly Ben would have just
like been boiling down you're a freakin
idiot your girlfriend's dumb for
thinking that that's what my girlfriend
thinks
because I definitely don't watch a show